when he comes around with Bieber walk
ain't nothing he can't do with a gift
that's why nobody never been able to
pick up his toys and things that I got
robbed a billboard walk and I'm a legend
of the blue not always from a little boy
I love I want to be looking I want
everybody looking at me I wanted to beat
one of the guys that everybody said dad
he ill that's what expired meter ready
to make me want to be a musician the
cool thing about build a walker is that
he grew up in the same Mississippi Delta
blues environment it's like Charlie
Patton or Robert Johnson or muddy waters
or Howlin wolf for BB King and when he
performs it feels like that is like a
living fossil just use one little ICD
it's not radon nightclub it's more like
a juke joint is what the people live
down in Mississippi
it's out there in the boonies not even a
town it's just out in a field and I also
love the fact that it's just so hard to
find right til your edit I didn't want
open in town because I only got two
minute
I didn't we got no roof from the ground
or from stretch that's right we built in
him and put it on the ground
it's an old army barracks Quonset hut
cut in pieces moved on his property
himself real authentic juke joint is
gonna be african-american owned because
it comes out of that culture and it's
gonna probably have a big personality
behind it this is seven years I've been
on this thing but it wouldn't have took
that long footage kept getting robbed me
data fluid come in got it you got
nothing in there place that makes you
won't just want to give up then I got it
I'm bitching about everything inside I
said no I'm not going I'm gonna give him
one more chance
[Music]
real juke joints that are still
operating with live music I can probably
count on one hand I used to say you know
you just you're not gonna get any more
as you're trying to suck that I would
have to say Bilbo's just gets
grandfathered in it's just such a real
thing and it's kind of an extension of
him and sort of what he's been doing his
whole life I wanted to be something that
people to remember me for see all the
new make people love you like that you
got to be different I wanted to come as
famous and then it's crazy ever been in
the world
[Music]
people asked me to sail for my day job
isn't what you do tedious as a
stop-motion animator you very conscious
of time and of incrementally moving a
three-dimensional object
bit by bit by dead mad God is a
stop-motion film that I've been kind of
making for like the last 30 years
there's nothing stopping me from
continuing doing it you know forever
[Music]
when I was 5 years old in 1955 I saw
King Kong on television as a stupid kid
I was just involved by Hollywood
monsters and that was really the thing
that kind of kindled my appetite
subsequently over the years I have worn
many hats in the motion picture racket
I've been involved with Star Wars the
Robocop series Jurassic Park Starship
Troopers on and on one of the things
that gives me a lot of pleasure is is to
make something but the day job has
certain requirements to it over the
years those requirements have become a
lot more limiting the Mad Dog project
allowed me to just make this more pure
thing that was kind of a form of therapy
for me as an antidote to my day job
it's a combination of live-action and
stop-motion miniature sets in layers
like a collage for lack of a better term
it's a passion project and things keep
getting deeper and darker and honor
there are imaginary cities that are
built out of iron ingots there's like
strange jungles that you go through
there's this huge de stop ik
post-industrial nightmare city and it
just goes on and on and on exactly
anything that I can think of inherent in
it there's a level of surprise that I
think you know for me is a very
childlike kind of a thing I shoot here
at my studio in Berkeley it's stocked
with all kinds of stuff for all kinds of
different electronic projects
woodworking projects lights cameras so
it's a huge toy box all of the
characters in that God are built by me
the process begins with the articulated
skeleton and that's made by Valen socket
or hinge joints that allow you to move
the characters incrementally one frame
at a time and then I just wrap lengths
of polyurethane foam and build up the
general mass from there I will take
latex skins adhere them with rubber
cement paint the thing and then it's
ready to shoot when you're actually
shooting a stop-motion scene you project
into the character and sometimes it can
get very complicated
you are always gauging acceleration and
deceleration weight and mass and then
that kind of leads to but you know what
what would make it better
for me this whole process is more of a
confession I really have no say over
it's just something that I I have to do
yeah I've been doing it so long it's it
I breathe I live and breathe in this
world it's all I think about
first time I met Miss Louise never shall
forget we met I had an eye you know and
that must have been love at first sight
[Music]
this is Charles Lala Evans all right
here we go
he and his wife Louise lived in this
house in Starkville Mississippi we will
marry
59 years in 11 months and we will 1
months after 60 years we almost made 60
after she died while I created a unique
tribute to her I decided I do this in
memory of her and we call this Lala and
Louise's place it's his personal
memorial to Louise made up of thousands
of photos this is it
this is it everywhere we went we took
pictures you know you stayed over there
never make a good one you stayed over
here that'll make a good woody hold it
hold it hold it click we had talked
about it default she passed it one thing
we want to build a museum to put these
pictures in we didn't get a chance to do
that but the idea never left my mind and
so I said I'm going to do it anyway
this is 1968 we were going dancing
somewhere back in those days dancing was
a big thing when I first met my wife she
couldn't dance and she just got tired of
that she said you won't teach me how to
do that and after I told her we were
such a smooth couple you know we didn't
we didn't miss a beat man this is my 33
collection fold tops look at that the PO
tops man
oh how players 45c oh man yeah oh did we
issue yes we did this right here our
last dance I'll never forget it it was
in July and I took her spinning around
dipped it for the last time brought her
back up and put one of them over you
know the following Friday is when she
had a massive heart attack and she
wasn't responding you know all of a
sudden she looked up at me and said I
would help you and that was it
okay change another god we had such a
beautiful life I got so much to remember
and I'm just living a beautiful memory
[Music]
the idea came from my father he told me
that there are pictures on the walls and
the subway stations of old buildings now
old New York
20 years later after going through
everything school college and all that
stuff I thought I'd be fine and give it
a look and to see what my father was
talking about
it was going to be a short article as an
illustration station with some pictures
and tell stories
but kind of run away with me
what I set out to do is make a record of
the appearance of the subway stations in
New York City
I take drawings of the mosaic or fans
designs on the walls which embellish the
station
I devoted much of my time as I can to
doing it evenings weekends vacation time
even you know it's all it's a sort of a
consuming project so far I've completed
four volumes I'm one two three and four
my ambition is to take care of all the
lines until all four hundred nineties
496 569
1470 stations have been recorded and
soon
[Music]
why am i doing it okay
my purpose in doing this study is to
make a record of what we've got I want
to like document when it was done and
who did it so that's what I want to do
that's my focus is to give credit to
those who made it possible
I really started in earnest in 1978 and
I thought I'd get this project finished
too wrapped up by the year 2030 which is
only 14 years from now perhaps I have a
theory estimate and that suggests maybe
close to the 2040
I'll be you know 90s then if I can still
see
[Music]
pleasure doing the job is his payment
I'm committed to it that's all it's my
prayer is my purpose it's my life it's
become my identity so I know so you know
so no Lydia Tory Ella's Acuto di questo
Paco ecological radio cervando movimento
a natural chair Ramos Abbas Uccello
Kavala ethical sequencer mrs. Julia
Mallory Quay movimento viva voce young
chef aarón's of course that when we talk
often
yo portion over are you Nora mundo
entero amazing Tarot PP&E no regression
we their patients are called a finito
numero Quatro Oh Monica belly okay with
Robo nose activate the equalization once
a jockey so thank you pickle in a column
ETA to Randy to talk a foursome annually
nutritional mechanism in say to volchok
re with a wrist injury issue direct as
we may get the job on my way
crystal importante it is value decreased
apart
[Music]
AJ Lee toric perform a theory I bambini
oversee shaka shakalaka rule my unicorn
or Osaka mint okay return Robo bean and
kale or oh the Bella Bella Bella where a
second quad or a millimeter me apart
coke we especially take Juan doe versus
arimasu al tramonto case under solo a
llama guardo Meo coral larvae forever
creado the 1920 cosas que pasa Ned Temko
[Music]
[Music]
one of the Circosta realistic Adele
Tasca Regis it is okay look you know
signal Yankee Yaya Satan constant a
urologist England oh come on Lois
yes show me a Gras de por que para ver
que cuando nombre Koziol Cristo
enough Ethernet LAN yah minimus and
event de Cinco de vacas - en nuestra
cattigan think what they tell son use
[Music]
your numbers are ample salagadoola in a
hobbit or uyama your mucho
nurse to the other I get the tuna so you
love another tell Emily salary per
oculus love clusters Tanguma battery
stereo castle entrada nests are cupola
elliptical ro con una una cadena tagging
or halal Marissa no Kiribati another
you to the Royal Society go from a chasm
yes impossibly can you tell me like an
Italian billion poor kkw Chichibu goofy
voice lapel and socket enjoy yo mr.
Cotterell cuando yo era question
Holloman TV - oh no no ii ii ii really
really
Ariba gustaría dimensional and Estacada
you so important a mommy
[Music]
you